J P lays that down to Morgan geeki here's
geeky from a sharp angle that hit the mask
of Corell bris like a shot that goes
wide out to center right to geeki and
then Jake Sanderson has it back for
Ottawa Sanderson lead pass to Josh
Norris Norris shoots at the pad save
made by Jeremy slaman the one loss to
Ottawa Zoo up foring shot knocks that down could
shoot that goes off the mask of Swing here's Derek
forber snaps that pass ahead but reaching back
to knock that away was Kelly good stick there
by Parker Kelly now Shabbat up for Castell
Shane Pinto bangs it back around to Joseph
in the corner for terceo centers at Joseph
in shoots and slan made a point blank save
on that slot Swan with a quality save noris
puts that down ASU gets their first AWA jaru
banks that back for shabat lines and shoots San
save one three players picked three in a row in
the 2015 draft as that long shooter is glove
by San looks ahead for debras in comes Jake De
Bron he shoots a Corella makes the save on that
there's the first shot for the Bruins in some 15
minutes Cole wins a face off back to makoy
and P that scores it took 3 seconds on the
power play for the Bruins to take the
lead G it's clearly a set play but if
you see host knock's going to Fan out
corus Salo Little D to D and this is
a screenshot of Parker Kelly wants to
get in the lane but it goes right past
him on the short side and he gets all
of it he elevates it goes blocker side
BWI feeds that back for grizzli he goes to
buwi and shoots cor save rebound they Jam
away and zaka couldn't get a stick on that on
a two-year deal he's been a nice find for them
settled in their third line and done a good job
lead pass for James and re like in shoots and
corello got a piece of that corber back with it
bounces for p KN looking for marshan who knocks
it down Brad marshan is oh B hand shot stop by
Coro sneaky little play he's able to knock it
down and then little spin around as he gets
wedged off by ardam zuk that's a good thing
to have if you can be a Swiss Army KN the guy
who can play in all situations be trusted now
he steals it shoots a corpus got just a piece
of that time wind down here in this power play
shabat Works in along with sta Shabbat shoots
and slen keeps it out a little rolling Puck
it's a good entry by Thomas Shabbat he's looking
for the back door redirect this hits the post oh
Shabbat has a look back and that's the first shot
that a was had on the power play that might have
hit the post though in comom TR Frederick now
with a Chance scor another lightning strike
from the Bruins this time after an Ottawa power
play and it's two nothing Boston out comes five
hole and right back the other way Frederick
through the middle of the ice little curling
drag Play Short short side shelf and you heard
it hit the bar down but zaka is going to lead
Frederick Parker Kelly chips that back
in skipping Puck knocked away so this
week we're seeing one of the wrel in the
schedule that not a lot of fans like Ottawa
only plays Montreal three times and Boston
three times this year and now Shabbat that
was chickle that shot not Norris and now s
the wind in drops in C Shabbat with a hard
shot needs it back to Sanderson for Norris
with some time Norris has a look and shoots
s and save rebound Lo front knock away from kach
and brought back up by Cole he's got high with
him shorthanded Charlie Co for de he in shoot
and corus lines the that save on a two-on-one
gets across and extends and watch oh hits the
shaft of his stick knocks it right out of his
hand look at the view of that we had a great
sight line racing back is kachuck to pick it
up THS that pass for Matthew Joseph and he comes
Joseph is SL down shoot that's knocked away now
chck a long shot was knocked down in front
and now Kelly a chance that's deflect it off
forber here's CH back with it and Swan gloves
that vus olark won the vzna last year as the
top goaling League Pak Works in and now
Maran with a steel kick and a shot away
Cole plays that back to Grizzly with a hard
shot off the post and off the glass ma boy
and cor there's the one timer coras solo doesn't
even see it it goes right off the crossbar but
St B for path has been run
around by chitr tereno steps up
tereno Works set free for CH drops
it back for stla Beat It Down coms
it back across and score lips of
shabat let's take another peak of
this there's the backhand pass by Chan
ster no look pass by BS to put it on
a Frink white goes for jeru and the
lines have been scrambled with st
and B off now picked up by K Chuck in
shoots and San makes the save on that
opportunity offensive zone br kachuck
going to turn and fire this noris fol it
that shoots him a sharp angle at the side of the
goal Glo down by Joseph he G
by Josh Norris and the game is
tied wi at it good loose Puck battle thrown
towards the net there it's popped up okay
so did Joseph touch the puck and move it to
Norris is going to be the question here the
officials are confirming about it so Joseph he
does touch it and it does go to Norris yeah this
is going to be from that angle it does look like
he touches it and you're right Norris is going to
short hop that past Jeremy San short side in
the blocker here's another better look at it
now does Joseph actually touch it that would
be the question yeah I I have no goal on the
pl against
DCA kick back to shabbat Shabbat PS across
for teraso walks in and shoots scores
Tero power play goal and the game his
tied
let's take a listen to
this he puts it short size underneath the bar
that's a tough angle but what Drake bson spins
out of the way at the last second teras senko
gets it by him underneath the bar now he sees
it in comes de brus winds it on Shabbat
de brus feeds it back across from shoots
and car Mak the save up High Drops that
back for Maran winds his way in drops it
off for Coyle Charlie Coyle s a t Pur
makes the save and now picked up by
sta terceo makes his way off along with Shabbat
in comes stutler Tim SLA winds in Clayman down
SLA left side back to Sanderson takes and shoots
that pu deflected wide off the Stick of Coyle in
comes twistle again steps around Mar the in
shoots rebound oh chance for K Chucky F on
that PS back the other way with Maran Sanderson
back defending Maran in shoot scores bra Maran
overtime winner and Boston takes it three to2
and then it's a two-on-one situation coil's
going to get it over to Maran right away Maran
head up the whole way and he just picks his spot